this is the battlefield in Laos these
are government troops supported and
financed by the United States fighting
and losing ground to communist troops
many of them from North Vietnam fighting
in remote mountains in an obscure corner
of Asia it looks and sounds familiar
just when the United States is gradually
pulling out of Vietnam there is a rush
of concern that Laos may become another
Vietnam not so says the administration
and says why well the president won't
let it happen that's why I mean we have
learned one lesson and that is that
we're not going to fight any major Wars
in the mainland of Asia again and we're
not going to send American troops there
and we're certainly not gonna do it
unless we have a American public in the
Congress behind this but the assurances
from the secretaries of state and
defense now from the President himself
have not silenced congressional concern
this whole problem gets down to the fact
that for the last year or so we've been
heavily de-escalating the undeclared war
in Vietnam at the same time we've been
heavily escalating not only the
undeclared but the undisclosed war in
Laos and this is the type and character
of development in a democracy that I
think could be very very dangerous
indeed the concern of the Congress the
dilemma of the administration the
situation in the never-never-land of
Laos these are the subjects of our
broadcast tonight
piece by piece the story of the American
involvement in that war in Laos is
coming out Friday the president reported
67,000 North Vietnamese troops now there
yesterday the White House said that it
will issue a regular up-to-date account
of US casualties in Laos today American
jets from Thailand and from carriers in
the Gulf of Tonkin continued to fly a
heavy schedule of missions against the
North Vietnamese and
at Lau whose Vanguard has now pushed to
within 14 miles of the royal capital of
luang phrabang in the administrative
capital vientiane the Prime Minister
Silvana Fuma is waiting for the delivery
of the peace demands of his half-brother
and antagonists the communist Prince
Savannah Vaughan after years of secrecy
and silence we are now learning a lot
about loss less than six months ago when
the president was first asked about Laos
he left more unsaid than he revealed
there are no American combat forces in
Laos we have been providing logistical
support and some training for the
neutralist government in order to avoid
Laos falling under communist domination
as far as American manpower in Laos is
concerned there are none there at the
present time on a combat basis we do
have aerial reconnaissance we do have
perhaps some other activities I won't
discuss with other activities at this
time that was in September but last week
public pressure and what he called
grossly inaccurate reports caused the
president to discuss after all those
matters in a lengthy statement he still
did not tell all the president disclosed
no precise figures on the dimensions of
American air power being used in Laos no
accounting of the cost of our support
estimated at several hundred million
dollars a year no definition of the
degree of command as distinct from
advisory functions exercised by
Americans there inevitably the
presidential statement on Laos has
raised many questions as many as it
answered the questions clearly derived
from continued congressional and public
uneasiness over the war in Vietnam Laos
is a theater that war it could hardly be
otherwise for a thousand miles the
borders of Laos marched with those of
North Vietnam and for a further 300
miles Laos borders on South Vietnam
that's the geographical explanation for
the Ho Chi Minh Trail along which
President Nixon says the great bulk of
the men and supplies of the war
in south vietnam are infiltrated in
addition law shares 264 miles of border
in the north with communist china and
another thousand miles to the west with
threatened thailand to its south is
cambodia these strategic implications
are clear any change in the status of
Laos must send tremors throughout the
entire area
moreover Laos is terribly vulnerable
here is a country larger than Great
Britain with a population of less than 3
million people whenever it suits them
the more numerous and warlike North
Vietnamese can move into Laos and it's
been suiting them for the last 500 years
particularly during the recent years of
the war in Vietnam to control the border
areas of Laos was absolutely essential
to North Vietnam's strategy step back
only nine years in history and you find
it was Laos even more than Vietnam
itself that was the most important
foreign policy problem to a newly
elected president the security of all
Southeast Asia will be endangered if
Flay us loses its neutral independence
its own safety runs with the safety of
us all in real neutrality observed by
all I want to make it clear to the
American people and to all the world
that all we want in lay us is peace not
war a truly neutral government not a
cold war pawn a settlement concluded at
the conference table and not on the
battlefield
now what President Kennedy did about
Laos was to get an international
agreement to cool things off when he met
Khrushchev in 1961 the one thing they
agreed on was not to let Laos become an
active theater of war the result was the
Geneva Accords of 1962 signed by 14
countries including the United States
Russia Communist China and North Vietnam
these agreements provided for a neutral
Laos governed by a coalition of three
princes representing the three
main factions boon ohm the conservative
Savannah thorn the Communists and the
neutralist Savannah Fuma who became
premier the agreements also called for
the withdrawal of all foreign military
personnel the United States Julie pulled
out its 666 advisors but the north
vietnamese only removed a token 40 of
their 6,000 troops in laos thereafter
subhana fong and the communists walked
out of the coalition government and with
their pet lao forces stiffened by
increasing numbers of North Vietnamese
regulars they've been holding two thirds
of the country and a quarter of the
Laotian population ever since the purely
Lotion forces on either side are
generally considered mediocre and
unaggressive the best on the government
side are the clandestine army commanded
by general Phong Pao and fully paid
equipped and advised by the United
States the puppet law although trained
in North Vietnamese tactics and equipped
with Russian and Chinese weapons are not
considered very formidable either left
to themselves the opposing lowchen
forces would probably cancel each other
out the crucial factor in the equation
is the 67,000 North Vietnamese regulars
President Nixon says or in Laos now in
direct violation the president says of
the 1962 Geneva agreements in spite of
American equipment advice and above all
airpower
the North Vietnamese hold the military
initiative in Laos today the United
States is said to be flying an average
of 500 air sorties a day sometimes as
many as 20,000 a month against targets
in Laos most of these strikes come from
US bases across the Mekong River in
Thailand the White House said we made
our first b-52 strike last month but
u.s. airpower has still not been enough
to do more than slow down the North
Vietnamese forces in the past couple of
weeks they have moved deeper into
government territory than they ever
Barnard Cal reports on the resulting
situation and what it means Laos has a
way of vanishing for a few months each
year that's usually when the monsoon
rains begin about May that's when the
war dies down when the world forgets
that Laos even exists but then with the
dry season one side or the other starts
up the war again and Laos recurs so to
speak and that's the situation right now
the North Vietnamese have just retaken
the strategic Plain of Jars
these are losses newest refugees being
evacuated just before the Communists
moved in the most tragic victims of the
seesaw not so secret war in Laos are the
refugees the official estimate is that
about one out of every four Laos has
been a refugee more than 600,000 of them
some have been refugees more than once
Laos has the most displaced national
population in the world some of these
Lao refugees were relieved to get away
from the war but there are reports that
some were encouraged to gold to deny the
Communists the manpower of these people
what goes through the minds of these
refugees well I've talked with hundreds
of refugees from towns and village all
over northeastern Laos in the last six
months what they talk most about is
American bombing being told by the male
soldiers of the royal lao government
site to leave their villages and having
to do porterage that is carrying arms
and food for Pathet Lao soldiers the
thing they're most concerned about is
the bombing and particularly American
bombing until 1967 Lao bombing by t-28s
outnumbered is greater than American
bombing but starting in 1968 in
particularly in 1969 after President
Johnson stopped the bombing in North
Vietnam and diverted the Jets into Laos
American bombing has been a constant day
and night affair for the refugees they
say that the planes came over all the
time
shattered everything people cows
buffaloes houses rice fields schools
they say that there were ordinary bombs
napalm phosphorus and anti-personnel
bombs
they all say that they've lived for the
last two years mostly underground what
about American military fighter bombers
planes operating out of Thailand
attacking North Vietnamese positions in
Northeast Laos can you come in on that
oh I have no comment on that at all we
are armed reconnaissance but that has
nothing to do with bombing or any
comment on the reports of an escalated
American military commitment report see
larger bombers b-52s operating could you
comment on any of that sir
well I just might make sure you comment
we have no commitment in Laos our
military assistance in material is being
supplied pursuant to the requests of the
Royal Lao government and in consonance
with a Geneva grimace of 1962
but to any question that would request
an itemization of American military
involvement what would be the official
American apply here sir Oh certainly no
comment thank you very much mr. Benson
the official American establishment in
Laos is very much on the defensive on
these sensitive matters but one American
reporter based in vientiane recently
managed to slip into long chain the top
secret CIA supported base for guerrilla
operations against the communists
basically long cheng is a logistics base
they fly things in there and big planes
and fly them out to the front small
planes this includes soldiers we saw
half a dozen transport planes there
dc-3s Caribous the strip can take bigger
ones we saw about a dozen t28 unmarked
single-engine propeller bombers these
are flown by Lao and male pilots but the
Americans do all the maintenance and
these planes are part of a pool that
runs out of Thailand so an American
pilot will shuttle them back and forth
the real thing they want to keep secret
there most of all is that the US Air
Force runs Jolly Green Giant rescue
helicopters out of there this is an
admission that the u.s. bombs Laos and
you can hear the American Jets roaring
overhead and they lose about 10 or 12
Americans month here are their more long
kings in Laos nothing as big as long
Cheng but there are these little CIA
hideaways tucked in the hills there a
lot over a couple half a dozen or so
over on the bull events Plateau these
are used for trail watching maybe
sending in some people to cause mischief
once in a while there others up by the
Chinese border they're literally nearly
uh well they're hundreds of little dirt
runways and you know in
in Laos and these are used for military
purposes by the United States by
controlling the arms and the money the
u.s. in effect controls the war
buildings like these how's the
requirements office which is said to be
a kind of camouflaged military
assistance group there is a variety of
unarmed air support provided by air
America and Continental Air Services
which are usually referred to as CIA
Airlines they admit to operating more
than a hundred planes and helicopters
but they are not as forthcoming as to
the exact nature of all their
assignments
a ferry cargo and military supplies
around the country they also transport
military personnel the people of the
Antioch and Laos have been described as
the least urgent souls on earth to hurry
to be desperate or frantic the way a
westerner might be in the face of crisis
is looked upon with national
embarrassment as a confession of human
bankruptcy the ante on is a city that
can live side by side with its worst
enemies on one of the most locally
expensive pieces of real estate in town
you find the official residence of the
Communist Party law and its objective is
nothing less than taking over the
country and not far away another anomaly
you find the pot at Lau's accomplices
the embassy of North Vietnam even the
North Vietnamese may be a bit perplexed
to find themselves sharing a capital
with the Embassy of South Vietnam just a
few dusty streets away that is Laos what
else is Laos is that you can find the
Embassy of Communist China in the midst
of all this and everyone knows that
Peking helps supply the guns to the pot
at Lau and to the North Vietnamese in
their effort to make Laos a communist
state the greater the ante on panorama
is filled with odd political economic
contrasts there are Liao's who will
quickly agree but they know too that the
Liao's are powerless they are very
scared they know that there is war in
this country and most of them affected
but they feel that they are not capable
to influence the cause of the events a
funeral in vientiane for a cabinet
ministers pilot son it's reported by
americans here that the Liao's in recent
months have been losing an average of
more than 10 men a day
killed in action fighting the enemy in a
country of less than 3 million people
that's a lot of war death
for the United States one major priority
in Laos has been to try to introduce law
of Hanoi men and materiel down the Ho
Chi Minh Trail spilling North Vietnamese
blood on the trail would save American
blood in South Vietnam but the question
now was whether Hanoi will follow up its
latest successful offensive in Laos
there isn't an American in the country
who doesn't believe that Hanoi if it
should make that critical decision could
cut through the Royal Lao forces and the
u.s. bombing and reached the Mekong
River
what would the u.s. do then escalate in
Laos get out what that is the agonizing
question that North Vietnam can flame at
the White House but art kal CBS News the
ante on at the time of the Geneva
agreements in 1962 the united states
accepted Prince Silvana Fuma as prime
minister with some reluctance he was a
neutralist but he seemed to be more
neutral on the side of the Communists
indeed he was their candidate since then
he has emerged as a pro-western
nationalist if his position is now
threatened by the growing North
Vietnamese strength in Laos savanna Fuma
did not admit it to CBS news
correspondent bill mcLaughlin in Fulton
and pothole despite everything don't
need a box off we should not give too
much importance to this offensive if you
dumb all of course we have lost men of
course we lost some ground me but so far
it is not exceeded the range of normal
offensive play possible no Maura it's a
paw paw
I don't think this it fossil but the way
North Vietnam is acting Don lucky Castle
gives any indications oh no Vietnam
movies that the North Vietnamese wish to
commit the u.s. more deeply in the
warran Indochina
level she would you know what the extent
of the US military involvement in Laos
is do you know what the United States is
doing we yes
call when need arises we asked for
material aid we asked also for the
intervention of US Air Force's for
surveillance against infiltration and if
necessary to bomb the invaders what do
you think would happen to allows that
there was no US air support if we were
left to ourselves the whole country
would come communist the whole country
would be invaded by North Vietnam
however it's the duty of the United
States to protect us are you afraid that
Laos could become another Vietnam no
what I've always thought
to prevent Laos from becoming another
Vietnam that's why I've always rejected
the introduction of foreign troops it
allows your highness are you concerned
about the activities of the Central
Intelligence Agency in Laos yes I cannot
say anything about this matter
Prime Minister Silvana Fuma says it is
the duty of the United States to protect
us the validity of that interpretation
is precisely what the current
controversy over Laos is about CBS News
correspondent Marvin Cal discussed it
with some concerned senators senator do
you believe that the United States
should be in the business of protecting
Lotion independence I do not I don't see
why 10,000 miles away we have to babysit
the world and John Dom the world at the
cost of many billions of dollars a month
in these countries when at the same time
we know how desperately we need this
money for the growing domestic problems
at home but high and I think most of my
colleagues wish is a disengagement of
both in both Vietnam and Laos these
recent activities in Laos make us
apprehensive that we were getting deeper
involved there a deeper involvement we
are undoubtedly doing more to end the
whole involvement then
has ever been done before by the Kennedy
or Johnson administration's who were
building it up naturally with the
president's great success in
de-escalating a Vietnamese war it's
essential for critics to talk about
something else
hence they've grabbed it Laos in the
hope of creating an issue there
I think this ploy is gonna fail I think
it's too transparent it's ridiculous and
in relation to our commitments in
Vietnam which are heavy and unfortunate
our commitments in Laos are of a
different nature they are our
commitments to protect our troops in
Vietnam I don't know why we've fallen
into an attitude in some parts of this
country where we think it's alright to
use five hundred bombers a day against a
country and then say it's a very limited
operation that we're going to be careful
not to put in ground forces I might say
that that's how we got started in
Vietnam we had helicopters over there
and reconnaissance flights and advisors
and we were given assurances that we
weren't going into a land war in Asia
but we've got five hundred thousand men
in on the ground now the President and I
say I support him I know that he has
great problems and he hasn't his choices
are very limited but I think the risk it
involved in taking our small number of
troops out of there is so much less than
the risk involved in perhaps the North
Vietnamese making a larger war I think
the risk to take their to get out
whatever may be the ultimate intentions
of North Vietnam and loss it is clear
that they have already succeeded in
disturbing the mantle of calm with which
President Nixon has wrapped the Vietnam
debate in this country the
administration's dilemma arises from the
fact that in spite of all that the
United States has been able to do for
Laos short of ground combat Hanoi still
holds the country at its mercy North
Vietnam can take laws it has been able
to do so for years had it been willing
to pay the price
however Hanoi may not be aiming at a
military convoy
with all its legal and moral
implications and with the risk of
military overextension North Vietnam may
instead be trying to create the
conditions for a political rather than a
physical takeover
that's what potted lao Prince savanna
fawns invitation to discuss a new
coalition government sounds like such a
solution if it is a solution would
present the administration with problems
only slightly less painful than whether
to introduce ground troops to stem the
tide in Laos a communist dominated
government in Laos would cause
consternation in Bangkok and Saigon to
places where the American commitment
still runs the North Vietnamese are
experts at discovering and exploiting
contradictions in American policy that's
what they're doing now in Laos they see
the war there as an extension of their
war in Vietnam and they're forcing us to
see it that way too
as long as the war in Vietnam continues
Hanoi can cause us much distress in Laos
it is an opportunity they are not likely
to forego this is Charles Collingwood
goodnight